what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host I'll sake on now we're
sitting down David wah
hi boom both sup man what's up I'm super
pumped to have you I'm pumped to be here
yes we're really talking about powering
cannabis across delivery point-of-sale
compliance he commerce all this good
stuff thanks all that stuff thanks to
meadow yeah yeah
so meadow came about three and a half
almost four years ago now yep yeah what
would what was like the moment for you
where you were like aha I need to get
involved this was it so 2014 Colorado
was going you know was implementing
their adult use plan and at the time I
wanted to build or help build a company
and edible company with my wife and so I
went to Oak stream University and East
Bay yeah right Oakland yeah the BART
station at the BART station and what was
amazing about it was we got to really
interact with the professors who have
dedicated their lives on pushing the
cannabis movement forward yeah and it
was medical cannabis you know we were
really focused on that so we learned a
lot about the you know the advocacy side
of pieces and sort of where it's come
from but then on the operational side as
a dispensary owner it looked really
fragmented there was a lot of manual
operations was a lot of pre tedious and
knowing that the regulated environment
was coming you know we decided to start
building tools for dispensaries and we
started with get Medicom and and that's
where we built out pretty much one-hour
delivery you can get cannabis delivered
to your home through a local dispensary
so opened up pretty much a whole slew of
options that could be brought right to
your door and you needed to login with
your medical card yep on the platform
yeah I'm both
a web app so on either mobile or on a
laptop computer or desktop computer
exactly mm-hmm and so you identity in my
in 2014 you were starting to build this
out yep and he launched in October and
so this is fascinating your wife is is
involved in this as well well she was me
she wanted to make edibles okay and so I
you know continued on that I brought
some you know with us for today and then
we went to the route of building out the
the software and so me and three
co-founders Rick Harrison Scott who I
worked with at a company called
sincerely got together and we're working
on a bunch of ideas and then decided to
dive into to the cannabis and that's
that was beginning so we launched in
October 2014 in one-hour delivery that's
really fast well it was really great I
mean we partnered with really amazing
operators our first partner is a vapor
room that was the first dispensary I
went to as a medical card holder here
and in the Haight and yeah it's and the
reopening in the in the Tenderloin you
know in a few months so we're excited
about that who would be the ones driving
the goods the dispensaries okay
so yep okay so then the dispensaries
then have a driver that would take maybe
an ounce or a couple ounces with them
out and then drive to the different
locations that have ordered through you
and sometimes the driver will just stay
out because your logistics system can
pain him or her and say that oh by the
way there's a new order that's just a
couple blocks away for you to drop off
yeah but like the way it works yeah the
way it works now everything has to come
from the premise so if like I want to
just do it from the car can't it's not
like mobile dispensing now you have to
go straight into it straight from the
dispensary to the patient back and forth
so it's more of like a hub-and-spoke
model okay let's let's let's walk them
on the demo so I'll show you let's let's
do I'll show them the site first and
then kind of and then we'll show it will
order through you okay okay so I can
kind of navigate with us
here so I guess we're on Ron do you see
it on your end okay cool so right so I
have an era with me I think you probably
want to roll a joint we'll just we'll
buy a cartridge so I like the pax era
okay
what's cool is on the left hand side you
have a bunch of filtering options so if
you click on concentrates Wow yes
straight up sativa indica hybrid hybrid
CBD flowers concentrates pretty real
edibles topical seeds said wow this is
real so here's flower look at that see
ya Dubai THC percentage yep Wow
yeah so they they filter it out by a
number of different sub options which
are great which are great yeah yeah I
don't see your designer it's just really
good thanks man
yeah associate that's it a team of a
couple or is it just one or
well the main desires my co-founder
Harrison awesome definitely let them
know that it's it's really well done man
yeah it's really well there we are
so I'm gonna check out the Blue River
pods from pax era okay hold on bumm
looking for something with a little bit
more CBD okay so for this I like a
bigger more CBD it's just better in my
opinion oh it's from spark you said
right yeah well order from spark I like
warning local it's like right down the
block right down the block
what was it what was it called in the
Blue River Blue River yeah there I
thought boom so I'm gonna go with the
Maui strong Nana so you click right here
yeah you pack blue river packs pod Maui
Stern and a half gram for $85 yeah Wow
then boom look at this page Hybrid
sativa your THC 63 should we should we
show them what you're doing a bit as
well or so I'm going to add to cart'
okay so you're okay so you're adding the
car right now on your mobile phone okay
okay boom now half grams in the cart yep
and then you're going up to this top
right corner yep for delivery exactly so
if you click on that cart I'm gonna add
a dress with the clash and then just
gonna place the order so this is it
really
well this I'm gonna place the order nice
boom and then I see a address apartment
payment method delivery yeah I think I
like that oh yeah let's let's show that
to that camera okay so on his on his uh
so hold hold hold hold it in place okay
and we'll let we'll let Ron zoom in on
it so we see that says 30 to 60 minutes
what else does it say just says your
order will arrive within 36 now and then
you can get it give $10 the same kind of
promo that many people do nice that's so
cool I mean this is so um switching back
to the program feed over here on do you
see look at this I mean this is this is
really well done well there's also a lot
of products right right because like if
you get off of the concentrates area
your your people are locations yeah so
like check out as a fog you click on
that they're awesome yeah they're good
you know they have some amazing flower I
just had the other day
the purple tangi was really good the so
your stolen concentrates and that the
filtering on this right side so if you
click off that and you'll see everything
and got blackjack from calyx that's
that's pretty solid I mean this is a
step towards the future yeah it's a fun
step towards the future yeah awesome I'm
excited so that I'll be here in 3060
minutes will you know will get a chance
to see the product come through the door
and get the labored and then yeah and
the less traffic's bad where we are
through yeah and then maybe you could
even yeah unpack it and she you know
that's this is the future he's getting
it delivered right to us yeah cool so
we're Ronnie throwing the David and
simulation back up yeah cool um alright
so that that's that's um that's so so
epic okay so now let's so that's like
the deliveries yes and that's where we
started and you know when we we
graduated from Y Combinator on what you
will classes win or 15 okay so that's
class like 10 or something or I mean
that's a lot only
that's a lot of money yeah it was like
one of 15 and we want then launched a
doctor service called meadow MD where we
would go to people's homes with the
doctor and do a house call wow it's
super old-school so you know we had
doctor Dan price was work is working
with us and we were we iterated from
bicycle to chauffeur driving to
eventually a boosted board just boosting
around the city to then now a
telemedicine offering okay so it was it
was really cool kind of like going
through that during YC and when we
graduated then we started working on
meadow platform and meadow platform was
really the the idea of building tools
for dispensaries building more software
that would help them scale their
business or make it run more efficiently
exactly yeah so that you know with
meadow platform we built out the
e-commerce side and eventually from the
e-commerce side we built out more robust
back-end tools like inventory manage and
patient management and then from there
we built out point-of-sale and so if you
go to a number of dispensaries you know
something we just mentioned you will see
them running our delivery our pick up
our e-commerce or point-of-sale yeah and
you know it helps them run their ship
really smoothly but also keeps them
compliant yeah and with the new rules
since 2018 there's a lot of compliance
requirements and it's turned into either
it can be a call center or it could be
something that you you know tick off of
the box and you can keep running your
business but the there is more than
there used to be from you know prop 215
days I mean yeah you just you've nailed
all of it out so let's a little you
hated outlets let's like when should we
showcase the edible and it one now let's
eat some now okay all right let's do it
you down we'll get some with Ron as well
okay it's a marshmallow man we're not
some Marshman it's a it's an afternoon
delight
yeah and it's five milligrams it's five
milligrams yeah so we got flavours we
got which one cookies and cream peanut
butter birthday cake and brown butter
sage we peanut butter birthday
cake Ron what are you thinking yeah are
you got peanut butter all right well
then what we got cookies and cream let's
see here
all right peanut butter there it is
that's the one of the very far right got
that that's so so let's go cookies and
cream okay so let's open up this package
together roundish am I gonna go with the
one across from me okay so all right so
we're looking at the packaging who get
Melos dot-com so is this this is my
wife's company this is your wife's
company so she cares about yeah exactly
edible manufactured oh s--- low-dose
exactly just a little bit well you know
have you ever had like too much of an
edible I hate it it's when you've had
too much it's it's rough it's really
rough like being on a roller coaster
ride that will not end yeah but know
that you're not gonna fall off the
tracks you the anxiety is what makes you
feel like you're falling off the tracks
and so and it's different for every
person and stuff but this is like what
your wife's doing and what you just
mentioned is actually really crucial
because the recommended medical dose is
about 20 milligrams right
the single serving is 10 single servings
time and that's what they say but I
don't know I think for someone that's
new you can still feel like that doesn't
have high tolerance five milligrams
you're gonna feel for from you know
people with severe medical conditions
that need way more I mean yeah this is
not necessarily for them people that are
looking like for you know a little
taglines mellow out mellow out yeah this
packaging is beautiful Thanks so we are
tell her that yeah please do it's really
well done
yeah and so and I see you have all the
you know all the proper compliance as
all the lab testing you know it's really
good keep out of Rancho that's let's
open it up in the ingredients cannabis
sativa and then cane sugar corn syrup
peanut butter coconut oil vanilla see
the this is the the sativa is a red
Congo these hash made by gold seal their
local in San Francisco Frenchie cannoli
is the one that helped use it's an
ice-water hash so we take the the
material from the grower it gets washed
and then ice water hash is then dried
and that's what's used to infuse this so
it's full cannabinoid profile from hash
ice water Hamish Wow yeah so super clean
and then okay Ron why don't you come
over here and hit up your peanut butter
yeah kind of your peanut butter I'm
gonna have this which is cookies in
Korean this yeah okay so that one's
cookies and cream here's Ron's
peanut butter one yeah Ron it's in the
game in the game alright look
let me let me oops let me take a look
what do we got here we got birthday cake
that's the one that I wanted to take a
look at let's take a look at it so so
same thing here this is Eva cashew
butter no not sure yeah all right let's
wow these are just really each
individually made dude handcrafted
handcrafted
No look at look at Ron you got this one
too this is a birthday cake one this and
the peanut butter one little peanut
buttery and yeah you're gonna put her
keys and creamy you know
yeah the peanut butter was a peanut
butter pretzel
super fluffy is so fluffy
mm-hmm-hmm and even just barely yeah can
barely taste oh right yeah the pretty
delicious Wow
and they're made locally San Francisco
everything from the ingredients to the
flour to the hash everything's local you
guys live in the city yeah yeah
is is your manufacturing facility in the
city as well mmm yeah it's it's where
staff you know she she runs it it's been
pretty fun
she has a cookbook that she's working on
- about low-dose edibles with her with
Corinne and yeah it's been you know uh
but I think low doses is the future for
a lot of people because like talking
about it for LLC as well yeah for micro
dose for sure yeah for all different
types yeah even a beer or whatever the
whole well like the dosing you know an
alcohol you know if you're gonna have
one beer how it's gonna affect you you
know if you're gonna have a shot how
it's gonna affect you and cannabis and
LSD and a lot of other you know
substances it's like you you have to
come to some relative bar and how it
affects you and I think correct low low
slow it they don't slow a little bit
time it's better than you know adding
all at once because you can't take away
yeah and and the whole low dosing is
also keeps you quite functional as well
as the nice thing yeah versus getting
too blasted drunk to blast at Heidi to
blasted one whatever so okay now that
was delicious how many dispensaries is
she in uh well is in San Francisco you
get at a path aquarium harvest and pure
7:10 so within the city you can get it
and you know on cash in the Castro and
sunset in the financial district I mean
there there there
Congrats on on making an edible that's
on me it's deadly not me yeah I'll tell
you why exactly that's really well done
and then you know I would tell her
Congrats on meadow as well so okay
you laid out the groundwork I'm gonna
put my phone back down here so I don't
have to keep it in my pocket all right
yeah we laid out the groundwork so we
have starting up with delivery and then
you work your way into into the POS
market and then that includes of course
compliance as well as e-commerce all
that snow so those four things walk us
through kind of what that's how big is
the team now there's nine of us nine of
you yeah and so probably like four on
the engineering side of the answers or
so okay so now as you built out the
delivery service you were like okay
we're gonna get we're gonna get cannabis
from the different locations
dispensaries to the people that need it
close by to those dispensaries and we're
gonna provide them with a platform
similar to like kind of like the uber or
whatever like everyone's saying they are
but know that you would help them locate
that person that wants this the cannabis
and because usually the cannabis is
dispensary themselves doesn't have an
online e-commerce page yeah and so you
would kind of be that um that middle man
for them yet to get the product to the
to the user so okay now how now let's
start there and then we'll keep on
packaging the other ones how many people
were you were you guys having by let's
say every hour back in like 2014 and
then now how many people by every hour I
don't even know in 2014
I mean we were stoked when we have like
ten orders like you know I mean like a
day or the day yeah yes we're just like
great and it was it was amazing because
and Y Combinator we kind of dogfooding
each other's products so some people
that were more like-minded we're like
yeah I'll I'll use meadow and check it
out
you know I mean it's just like you know
I was trying their stuff they're trying
our stuff and got good feedback and
iterated accordingly now we do like
thousands I don't even know a day in
terms of orders yeah right applause like
everything that's right epic like it's
um and you're in you're in you're
outside of the Bay Area in what cities
as well oh yeah I mean where we cover
80% of Tolle territory in California
whoa
so we have presents in you know a lot of
these areas SF la are the two major
markets that you're in yeah well SF LA I
mean there's you know you can't forget
about some of the smaller cities like
Modesto Vallejo Sacramento Sacramento
right like those are really important
those populations bigger than some of
the markets outside of California yeah
right totally and that's that's the
beauty about California our size and the
fact that we've been here doing it for
the last you know 20 years since 90 or
22 years from 96 but you know decades
and decades and generations of growers
across the state so yeah we're we have
presence in a lot of the areas and the
the problem that we're seeing though
with 2018 is that the state has
defaulted local control default the to
local control correct so yeah and if
you're an operator you can't get a state
permit to operate unless you have local
permit yeah and you know currently 33
percent of the cities have some sort of
laws the rest don't even though you know
cannabis was voted in by you know the
over a majority and for Prop 64 back in
2016 so a lot of these local old
business local municipalities and they
all have to wrestle with ok how does
cannabis work within our our city how
does Taxation work how does zoning work
yeah and these discussions haven't been
brought up in a lot of area so now
they're trying to model off of cities
that have more sophistication so Oakland
San Francisco Santa
la everyone's putting their laws
together Sacramento there's there's
still a lot to be done now we're moving
into the compliance and the regulatory
side of things which is really
fascinating as well people that the
people that are like I hate it to me
it's like how does a society move from
something that is so taboo
yeah and illegal to something that is
legal and used for medicinal purposes
and for purposes of flourishing and all
the other ones that we'll get to soon
but that is a very interesting process
it's kind of like what we talked about
with the simulation theory is if you
were the creator of the simulation you
would be able to tweak all these
different variables and observe how the
society is becoming how its evolving is
there that's exactly what you're doing
is we're observing how cannabis is
evolving through culture yeah and so
okay so now with the rail it's like it's
so weird right because like cannabis
already exists right it's out there
already like it's and now you're putting
in the layer on top of it of rules that
you have to kind of you know come into
and conform to I got I gotta say that I
felt a bit of uh like just uh you know a
mellow just now a very seasoned lunch a
very some no okay no lunch yeah it might
work faster definitely no lunch
definitely no we don't we don't eat
until like 5:00 p.m. here yeah we do
kind of like an intermittent fasting
thing because you only do two vodcasts
in the afternoon and then we drop into a
dinner around like five or six or
something and then that's our food for
the day usually okay um but that's
that's probably part of it and then
other other thing it's just it's a very
very very mellow but it's it's you said
it was cold ice water ice water hash
yeah I still have to learn more about
that okay ash no well hash I know
hashing a cold water hash oh yeah I mean
I don't know give you a bit we should go
into into that but let's let's cover
let's cover let's see if we can get back
to that but let's start but go back to
the regulation Orion compliance because
okay so now with
state like Colorado
with the state like Colorado there's
it's different than a state like
California yeah so Colorado does do they
have the individual counties have to
decide how they want to yeah many
permits they I want to get well it's
interesting is like for the ones that
aren't involved the Oh necessary get the
tax revenue right and so it's what
you've seen in Colorado is that the
cities I've embraced it
I mean they've rebuilt entire school
districts and parks and everything in
California and we actually prioritized
you know not so much the education
education is hard because it's such a
big budget so the money is going into
helping people that have been ill averse
Lee affected by the war on drugs money
is going into a fund to help you know
basically bring them into the the
industry money's going into helping with
like quality control and making sure
that proper things are properly testing
you're getting good you know product you
know if it works out California could be
generating
over a billion dollars in tax revenue
but I think the key is to look at more
of a long term peace over taxing it now
has you know has bad effects right you
have no an illegitimate market no that
doesn't have their local permits and or
operating in the black market you have
the legal market but at the legal market
the tax is really high people want to
default into the black market yeah and
you know if your taxes are too high at a
city by city level yeah then all of a
sudden you are operating at a loss on
your business operations and you know a
potential competitor so you know it's
it's like you're already getting an
upside on the sales tax right like we
have the sales tax now and more people
are buying it because you know that's
adult use what is the current cannabis
tax so there's a fifteen percent excise
tax that's calculated between the
distributor and the dispensary
but that fifteen percent
is against a 60 percent markup in a non
arms-length transaction so that means if
it's a you know marketplace you're
spying then you're effectively playing a
twenty four percent tax right there and
then when you you know because it's
party cost of goods when a patient or
consumer is buying it they have sales
tax which taxes the entire product so
essentially it's taxing the excise tax
and then you have potentially local tax
so if you look at like wout then they
can't give real yeah I mean I'm not
gonna buy a gram for forty dollars
that's why I hope it doesn't get that
high and there's a lot I mean you're
seeing ace for like 80 bucks that's way
too high as well you can get the grace
for 40 you know that's so you're
especially for people that are doing the
patriot to paycheck and they're just
trying to you know yeah and so now that
the markets totally lopsided right like
you have medical patients that are used
to paying a lower amount so they may be
going back to the black market right and
then you have the adult use market which
people never are now coming in and
buying at the higher price so it just
it's it's a very you know we have to be
very iterative than this and it's gonna
continue to be more iterative with your
the regulations you said something
really interesting which was that the
counties that don't come on or artists
pea fall behind because not only are you
falling behind in terms of the amount of
money that you're making to fund schools
and transit you got that on a volume
like on a little too high fee so yeah
it's wrecking this well I've tracking I
have a map it already says it's here oh
whoa so you see like I have like Meadows
on the way four minutes away I can click
on this and then let's show that we show
the gallons also show the let's show
your cameras well so you know you can
see there right there on Market Street
over there
right oh so so your something moves oh
that's good
I think cool so they'll probably ring
the doorbell
well it will be good I did did they know
to come to a simulation well is that
yeah did you the address was it did you
give him the unit number as well I just
gave them then they'll call you though
right exactly so they'll give the once
they call David then he'll walk out to
the to the front door and grab it and
we'll we'll chat amongst ourselves for a
minute well that's fine just let us know
when they when they're here I can't
believe they're that fast was that 30
minutes no it's fast and that was in 30
minute I was like literally 12 minutes
15 minutes yeah
holy cow 15 minutes that is some that is
some Amazon Prime instant delivery [ __ ]
yeah I mean but that's the beauty of
being local I think you know my week I
tend to order where I'm wherever I am
the closest a because I like to sample
from a lot of different it's like
whatever four blocks away or yeah yeah
so that's also why they can just like
grab it just walk over and give it to
you or brick exactly yeah yeah yeah so
okay so I will wherever we stop on the
regulatory we'll pick up right when you
right when you come back yeah well
they're outside now say oh yeah go get
it yeah Gogi bringing right that kind
yeah Mike with you Ron and I will run
and I will chat while you go you guys
can chat yeah and then try and hold
pulled the front door open so you don't
get prompt so you don't get locked out
you got it you know I was thinking what
was that that we that I ate again the
peanut butter yeah the I was just
pondering how it's possible that our
entire solar system could be a tiny atom
in the fingernail of a giant human being
isn't that incredible that's remarkable
the the similarity between the atom and
the solar system is come on let me who
sit down over there yeah owww come on
get over here
so just or or or just speak you know as
close no it is good though I have not
actually um kicked in its nice mellow
it's not too extreme it's super mellow
yeah that's the whole branding is the
mellows
they're both marshmallows and it's
called mellow like the texture the
textures uh was was interesting yeah cuz
it's marshmallow yeah
it's a marshmallow and they're you know
the brandings great yeah the the five
milligrams buzz is very very very barely
noticeable and it's just relaxing you
know when you go ten or 20 that's when
you really start getting a little bit of
us think II think II high and you can
fall into anxiety edibles probably make
you a little feel a little bit more you
know I forgot to mute your mic I
wonderfully go oh we probably got him
outside or we might not have because it
was it's cool whatever you want no yeah
we're good yeah we're good we're totally
good so here's my receipt can you can
you still hear him okay okay good he's
right
there's my child proof bag there it is a
child proof bag well every frog needs
have exit packaging now
yeah exit package yeah exit packaging
which is like child-resistant and damper
proof how is this child resistance
researching about that's not though like
you have to do it's like a secret secret
okay so here's the normal oh no pop but
then there's another whether you open it
from here and then pull from this one I
know it's like this side this one yeah
oh oh oh that's that's that's
interesting got it
so that's how you can actually open it
yeah so we got some rosin sauce I guess
it's your over here these hold it hold
it hold it in place and he'll fills in
from Blue River so these guys are pre
legit and they do extraction for full
flavor from the plant
so are you how you know I guess they
very stacked with what what method
ethanol I think will they do full flavor
extract I'm not sure their extraction
method the whole flavor extract yeah
yeah but so they don't plant derive
turkey they they don't have herpes yeah
they don't add terpene Dulce and we got
some Maui strawberry banana good oh my
god this is great they give you a
receipt to me never seen thicker well
there's like requirements on that yeah
exact so you know part of the
regulations you have to have like who
deliver it when you have to sign for it
yep yep so here's the the mouth this
smells ridiculous
oh my gosh holy cow this smells
ridiculous so I'm gonna replace this pod
oh my god this pod Maui strawberry
banana yeah right and then just like pop
that in there
this pod so
so this is the packs
what is this attack Sarah the packs era
yeah
er a a our era
smooth oh that's very smooth right yeah
Ron you want to come in
yeah sure
come on Ron it is very very smooth yeah
super smooth and so you got the the pods
which are provided by packs but then you
have basically the the partners that
fill it so damn son I know he took a
little child it's fine
you're still tasting I always I'm doing
the tasting Ron went over here like good
job good job
Ron okay fill this listen yeah yeah
absolutely right back yeah right back at
the sink interesting these packs are
where's you put the you put the other
one in here oh this is also childproof
oh for sure man for sure okay so now the
packs charges electrically yeah the bond
must be a little mini USB right there
and then and then the the cartridge
itself it powers through these two ports
here that just connect it and then they
burn what does it burn a wick or like a
metal wick or something like that how
does it add heat to it nice um let's see
how does that add heat to it so that
battery conducts the heat goes through
this heating element inside and then
that basically carboxylates the the oil
and there you go and then it's ready to
write as you go so there's the you know
here's the here's that's the right
that's the Maui all right and you have
different sort of operators
that's the Emerald Oh infuse though
here's the bottom of it too
yeah and this is like work goes ah I
focus it's cause it's on your face but
that's good thank you thank you Coulomb
let's let me give that are we having fun
yeah we're having super fun we're super
fun super they're super fun I loved the
and y are we having fun we're having
super super fun right yeah so this is
but now he's strong Anna Maui strong
Anna jeez the way they the flavors are
just Maui strong Nana yeah yeah it's
just gonna be one of those smashes thank
you
Ron you're doing great wrong hand Ron
took the the producer takes a massive
hit it's gonna be fine
professional yeah yeah okay all right so
back back at this counties that are not
getting on board or typically ending
appalling behind and counties that do
get on board get to benefit by hopefully
making taxes on the product that are
fair enough to where they can help fund
schools and transit and all this good
stuff but at the same time not affect
the end user so much that they end up
going black market instead so that's
kind of been this general balancing
principle yeah
okay but also you know I would add one
more piece of that and that's local jobs
right like yeah the fact that you can
create jobs right now is everything yes
especially in a municipality level right
yeah if you look at glad you're adding
jobs
yeah well it's adding a whole new
section because it's not just the jobs
within the industry it's the lawyers the
accountants the trademark attorney is
the real estate brokers the you know the
the packaging people that everything
it's a whole ecosystem there's and and
people that build the POS is you know
that's the way outside of that so the
lawyers and the
oh just think about the electricians and
the plumbers now you come in and install
you know gross or if you're doing
manufacturing thing about the kitchen
equipment that they have to buy like
it's it's everything all the ingredients
everything you create this whole
economic engine yeah that if it's done
well because the pie is big you'll need
a huge sliver right you can just need a
piece of it just to so it spreads itself
out because there's already economic
value happening you know how they say
that uh data is the new oil data is the
new oil people say that people have said
that yeah okay I think the new oil the
new oil I mean this is about to say that
same thing so okay let me I want to
follow up on that jobs this huge
expansion of the economy is huge it's a
massive thing to be able to do and to
provide people with survival and
livelihoods so important yeah so this
this kind of reminds me a bit about you
know Oh a ice taking so many jobs or
robotics is taking so many jobs but one
of the my favorite things to talk about
is all the new creative work that's
gonna be made by being a by being the
the human-computer interface or
interaction designer with a robot or the
one that needs to to put a program
philosophy and ethics into AI you know
there's so many new jobs that are also
coming with that market as well so I
think cannabis might be putting a couple
of the tobacco companies and alcohol
companies a little bit back but at the
same time to use some jobs but at the
same time they're creating a lot of jobs
so I mean I think it's hard
cannabis is like really in the infancy
stages of where it's going now that it's
it's illegal right when you look at
tobacco and you look at alcohol that you
mentioned these are decades long the
industries have had regulatory iteration
after regulatory iteration after health
you know issues and and all these things
I think for us it's really about
learning from what the best practices
that are in these other industries and
make it and bring that into cannabis but
still allow have its own thing and
yeah I think you know one area you're
seeing that alcohol and tobacco don't
have is the medical side and right you
have this whole medical cannabis adult
use cannabis medical cannabis can help
with a number of conditions halls really
not like you're not gonna take it to you
know for cancer you know that's not
gonna happen you're gonna take it for
sleep you're not gonna take it from
eating young you're not gonna take it
for pain yeah yeah
and so when again the medical side then
you have another huge competitor or area
which is pharmaceutical end right and
the pharmaceuticals they have a whole
nother set of regulations if it's truly
a medical right the clinical trials and
testing but because it's a Schedule one
it's not you know cannabis isn't open to
testing we publish less than ten papers
a year probably on cannabis testing
versus Israel I mean they publish like a
hundred a year right and so their
population is just such a small fraction
yeah exactly
well because the government realizes
that you should be testing and like
really understanding and it yeah and so
there's a lot that goes on but you know
one thing's for sure when you look at
cannabis legalization across the state
or across the country medical is usually
the first you know piece to come right
and then after a while there's a medical
program okay then you have adult use and
in California we have medical for 20
years we've just added adult use this
year and changed medical completely so
now we're in this whole nother phase and
the way this thing goes yep I wonder if
there is a sort of best practice to if
medical cost should come first then
recreational should come yeah
do you think that that's a best practice
or personally I think so
mainly because what's great about
medical is that you know if you have a
great consultation from a doctor then
they should be able to open your minds
about the possibilities of cannabis and
how you use it for yourself for your
lifestyle for your condition whatever
you're doing
oftentimes people are introduced to
cannabis through a friend like hey check
this out smoke this and you're like oh
that's cool but that friend may not be
as educated and know that all right
within your endocannabinoid system you
know currently you're dealing with sleep
issues right so maybe you should try
something that is a little bit more
heavy indica so try from these family of
flowers if you don't want it flower then
maybe you should try and edible start
low and go on and go you know so forth
and then have the best night of sleep
ever or in a long time I think you you
find that it the the social introduction
is great but then the the medical
benefits or the the lifestyle benefits
can be totally dialed in yeah depending
on what you or how you consume than what
you want to consume personalization yeah
that's in an industry that is kind of
being birthed right now is this whole
personalization to how people learn what
people watched or what people consume as
food in us technology and health care
and socialized shoes yeah and so now we
have personalized cannabis which you
know makes perfect sense for the
individuals that want to foray into it
that they have a
you get to experience it for the reasons
that you need it okay so okay that's
what's going about it right and like if
you look at some of the other states are
starting to introduce medical usually
you're seeing it from the heaviest
proponents are parents they're going
after you know getting medical so that
their kids with epilepsy can get access
to it or they're going for it for for
cancer or you know HIV in San Francisco
medical started here like just down
there Castro and it was started by a man
who just passed away recently his name's
Dennis Peron so this guy right here he's
uh you know he's one of the he's the
very god father of medical cannabis
Dennis Perrault Dennis Peron absolutely
for sure so he he's amazing so what
ended up happening his his lover passed
away from HIV this is what year this is
94-95 okay right and after he passed or
during his HIV medical cannabis was one
of the few things that helped him but
after he passed then Dennis was like
okay let's make this accessible to
everyone because at the time HIV
epidemic in San Francisco was called
what grid at the time or something like
that where it was decimating it was
really bad it was really bad yeah and so
Dennis author prop 215 it got passed
medical began at a collective model so
the collective mono was all about hey
I'm growing you're part of my collective
I want to share my medicine with you you
have a certain allowance that you can
have I have a certain allowance but
together we can share in this bounty
yeah and it's it's what we've been using
for the last 20 years yeah and created a
whole you know movement or now you know
industry again birth from a story birth
from a reason or a purpose but birth
from a person who like really needed it
for someone they care about and you know
when you look at these mothers are
fighting for their kids with epilepsy
are fighting for access for chronic pain
yeah wait so there are a lot of people
now that have seen this whole opioid
crisis and this whole addiction and do
not want to go down that road
yeah and if you look at medical cannabis
when it's introduced into a state opioid
overdoses go down you also find that in
conjunction some people a lot are able
to wean off of that of the opiate
correctly and so it's it's one of these
things where there's a there's a health
epidemic across our country and people
dealing with pain people Beyonc mental
illness or health and I think cannabis
can really help that and medical is a
great onboarding to get there if you
want straight-up adult use you might not
have the education that people need
because you've been there I've been
there like yeah if you just took a 50
milligram at a bowl you're you're
elsewhere or if you like dad on you know
first on your first time you're gonna
just your two-hour laid out laid out and
laid out so you're you're absolutely
right this sort of as a as a this
beautiful substances whether it's you
cannabinoids whether it's psychedelics
whatever the these substances that are
coming into the world right now how
they're coming in if we take a medical
perspective on it first if we put the
medical lenses on it first it will
generally educate us with the foundation
we need to then understand how it
assists people and also how we can
responsibly use it as adults as well
with the adult use so I really like that
yeah yeah it's a cool damp love it
all right how about we touch okay we
just did some of the regulatory and
compliance I have so many friends that
are like oh I'm trying to get this
county up north to get money grow
another buddy of mine down south is like
between LA and SF I'm trying to get this
county to let me grow yeah you know
and it's a local issue yeah it's such a
right and that that becomes the advocacy
side then you like get to know the mayor
oh you know the mayor is important but
the Board of Supervisors or their City
Council or more exactly the port IceCube
see because like you're dealing with
zoning you're dealing with districts
that have maybe high tolerances or low
tolerances to NIMBYism right like it's
okay but not in my backyard so you have
to regulate it accordingly and then like
if you don't do enough then all of a
sudden you have landlords that are for
xing their rent and then you know also
playing this game of trying to you know
all as much as they can they'd 4x their
rent on that bread and then all of a
sudden the numbers don't work out it's
just like this fine balance that you
really want to open it up and let the
market decide but it's not to the market
decide oftentimes it's the local
government yeah that's a crazy that this
is up to local government now to take
issue so I would just quick and one last
thing about this is permit wise you know
San Francisco how many like permits do
they give out versus how many would like
a county in the middle between LA and SF
that you know that only like a thousand
people it's really interesting right
because you have San Francisco which
permitted dispensaries that had grows
attached to them this was you know for
the last however long we've been doing
it in San Francisco and what ended up
happening is there weren't licenses for
manufacturing for distribution for the
labs these were licenses that were
defined at a state level so of a sudden
you have San Francisco I'll playing
catch-up with the state to create
license types that allow local
governments to issue them so that the
operator can then go to the state so
what ended up happening in fall of last
year there was a registration period for
operators with those license types they
register once they registered this year
the the office of cannabis headed by
Nicole Elliot worked with four other
five other departments Department of
Fire Department of Health
by electric and water planning they all
came into each of these operations to
inspect and to make sure that the
compliant and in order to give them a
permit to operate a temporary permit and
so that's how it works in San Francisco
but if you look in San Jose every
operator is verticalized there's 16
dispensaries and they have their own
grow and they have their own store but
you know now they have to issue more
manufacturing and all these pieces but
you know way more in a way different 16
though yeah different in those cities
and then 16 in San Jose what about this
perm what about this County like that's
in Central Valley you know they're
either deciding to give out no permits
or they're giving out one or two
insisting it's totally nuts right
there's look at Calaveras County right
they initially said ok we're open for
business come and apply for a license
and then everyone did and then all of a
sudden a whole new board you know board
for Supervisors got elected so you know
what we don't want cannabis banned it
and what I did one of my most buddies
got yeah two million dollar property or
someone exactly people invested millions
and millions of dollars into these
entities parcels and also the
application fees and so now like people
are suing the city saying hey like you
can't do that and like it becomes this
whole local you're you know bureaucratic
political battle correct that's yeah and
yeah and we will we're gonna get closer
to these open doors to be able to bring
it to the world
okay now this that's so crazy with the
compliance in regulatory right one of my
is seriously one of my favorite pieces
though is like if you don't get behind
it
you're just gonna get surpassed by other
counties that are getting behind it's
the same thing with AI if you're just
gonna be like no we don't need AI and
our sis County okay great well your
County is just gonna fall behind in
general yeah so well it's also if you
look at these municipalities a lot of
more kind of under water right they
don't have you know really strong
streams of revenue in fact a lot of
their revenue
tax revenue has to go to pensions and
benefits and all these things that are
big part of their budget so when you
have a whole new industry that could
potentially create jobs and also create
an ability for people to you know bring
some money back into the coffers it
could be a huge economic boon for the
for the the city definitely ok so we
have now going into let's talk a little
bit about the POS that you guys built
out sure this that's in how many
dispensaries now over forty thirty
dispensaries are using your POS yeah
that's great that's a huge scale and
achievement yeah it's really you know a
testament to you know we tried to grow
through really great partnerships and
you know what we've done is we found
partners across the state that saw
technology as a way to you know put some
leverage into their business yeah and to
operationalize it to get to compliance
yep and exactly we're and then that
makes all the legal work easier all the
accounting little easier holidays and
I've heard it that this is really bad
yes we have so many friends that are
either growing or selling or or doing
whatever with the managing the
dispensary and accounting is I've heard
from so many people that is just one of
the worst parts about it so if there's a
POS that makes it super easy then use
that yeah okay and then the e-commerce
side of things it's about you said a
thousand a day or around that that's on
thousands and thousands that's amazing
that's a great scale great skill that's
getting there yeah I think like step by
step small steps every day that's what
we say small steps updating it and you
know you got mellow as well get mellow
which is great with the wife okay so you
know we hit we had a bunch of buns Donna
stuff with health benefits is when all
we covered which was great we did yeah
and we had a delivery yeah it's amazing
so okay let's do a little bit on the
tech to end because I think we touched a
good amount about it with these you know
these slim vapes this pax era is you
know it's a big deal you just keep
looking how small it is just put in your
pocket whip it out amazing raising so so
there is those there's the kangertech
associated with you know get mellow you
know these little five milligram edibles
as well then there's the now I find this
to be really interesting I think we we
haven't touched on this yet I think we
should right now is the as we talked
about machine learning and all the
internet of things and all these
exploding industries they're being
leveraged for cannabis in really
interesting ways for example just being
able to grow vast swathes of cannabis
with sensors that measure how well the
plant is doing how much more nutrients
that it needs how many would what else
you need to feed it in order for it to
bud in the best way possible flourish
and then we are optimal for Harlow I
have kind of like a different opinion on
that but but what about the put the ppm
parts per million sure sure sure and to
make sure that the the pesticides and
herbicides are removed as much as
possible so again all the all that that
is that's technology there's definitely
tech there and I don't disagree and I
think like tech is often used for scale
but you know from my perspective and
this is just yeah for I've seen smaller
grows often have better quality because
if you look at what's happened with
cannabis for longest time no one really
super scale right a lot of cannabis was
craft it was you know under a hundred
plants and they're just trying to stay
under the radar he no one's trying to
have acres and acres right like you're
rated by the DEA yeah and so everyone
had to pour their heart and soul into
each plant yielding as much as possible
right and you know if you go up north or
some of these farms that we've seen you
know because they've been growing for
generations oftentimes there is no use
of pesticides there
you know totally bioavailable nutrients
from soil that they've been you know
cultivating over a very long period of
time you know true farmers right I'm
talk about farmers that grow other
pieces and crops on their their property
cannabis is just one and they you know
they do a full lifecycle on that soil to
other you know pieces you know there's
also operators that you'll reuse water
and like they have a whole water storage
system and then they go there when you
look at commercial or industrial
agriculture in our country it's you know
oftentimes their subsidy ssin that
happens there's like you know one farmer
on hundreds and hundreds of acres with
machinery that just goes and pulls and
things like that I don't know if that's
necessarily the answer for cannabis you
know I think there's enough there there
could be enough farmers and small
operators where it feeds into a larger
distribution system that then people are
picking and choosing you know that red
congolese the grower is or has been
growing red congo for over a decade yeah
so we're talking about someone that took
those genetics and ree bred them and
cross bred them and until it became this
you know this mother that crushes on red
congolese yeah and i don't necessarily
know if you could do that the same way
if it's like acres of it I don't know
maybe well I think we may be getting
back it may be getting there I don't
know well oh yeah I prefer this way what
about what about taking the og method of
having like trying to maximize the
beauty in the flourishing of this one
plan let's say when it was limited like
that what if we could replicate that
same beauty and flourishing at larger
scales and then also leverage tools that
would let you know if there was
something happening to assure you get
the notification but that only really
happens with good data right and like
that it's not these farms have had you
know massive amounts of data so it's
like you also almost need to feed it the
right way on how you're growing it and
certain scale and then go after it but
we've we've heard of plenty of horror
stories I mean you probably to too
people that have over-scaled had a pest
problem and then just like decimated
their grow and it's because they didn't
account for the higher humidity level or
higher moisture which then got powdery
mildew and then all that you know
nonsense that end up happening yeah
then to take all of these variables into
account as this industry comes to life
yeah is what you're what you're doing
what you're building and how you're
assisting empowering cannabis let's ask
you a couple of the simulation questions
what's the simulation question yeah no
yeah now you get to turn some tide all
right cool
all right let's let's ask you about this
we talk about this a lot on the show
yeah what are the most optimal ways to
maximize human potential
well I think potential is often
individualized right or it's something
like an external factor that say hey you
have a lot of potential or you say to
yourself I have a lot of potential right
oftentimes I think with cannabis it
gives you both of those right you are
able to take a different perspective a
different angle if you will on who you
are and or how you view the world and
oftentimes when you open that capacity
in in your mind it really opens up what
you believe your growth potential could
be definitely it's kind of like a
hallway where all of a sudden you've
opened all the doors or opened another
door and now I have a whole other way of
getting through into the room so I think
you know if you to maximize potential
first year realize that there's more
there or have you know assistance to get
there the expanding the mind to new
dimensions something we talk about all
the time it's so important yeah and
cannabis is like a perfect onboarding
for that right like because there's so
many different perspectives many people
yeah for some nah maybe not but like for
me it was right
I could giggle I could chill out I could
get energized I could sleep in
inspiration its inspiration you know I
could go and you know start writing in a
journal I could go on a hike it's just
it's so multi-dimensional that I think
it also opens your life to other things
right have you ever just listened to
Dark Side of the Moon just stoned and
just like hearing everything and like
the layers in it and like or just like
pick up you know
Kendricks new album like oh my god it's
like but then there's also going to a
movie when you're stone and then leaving
the movie going like yeah we do our best
here at sharing both yeah I'm sides of
the here's a cool thing like if you're
sharing cannabis over a joint or
whatever that opened
a human connection that openness shows
shows way more and it's like when you
have a six-pack and you pass a beer same
thing or when you have a big like a
couple bucks yeah and you want to say
someone's asked after a book you give
past long book okay how about I'm
interested to hear what your thoughts
are about this okay well what do you
think about the rapid accumulation of
wealth by a very very small amount of
people like about eight people have as
much wealth as the bottom four billion
people what do you think about that as
we move forward in the future an
unsustainable how do we yeah tell us
about your perspective and then maybe
how do we solve that if possible I
always solve that I know that my people
of my paygrade
I think like the over accumulation of
wealth
I mean what's interesting is some of the
people that were that had that wealth
have said they shouldn't have that
wealth you know they want to give it
away or they should be taxed higher and
you know pieces like that the
recognition that is important but it's
so hard when you're the deck is stacked
against you it's almost like I have a
two-year-old and she doesn't necessarily
go up the slide by walking up the steps
she like goes up the slide by like
trying to walk up the thing and just
amazing amount of friction to get up
there especially if you have like really
slippery shoes yeah right correct I love
doing and when you when you look at
where the the unbalance is you know
people people of color right have been
very affected on the war on drugs when
you look at our population of prisoners
the over the majority have been arrested
through a drug-related offense often
with grams in there of marijuana in
their pocket
now when you remove those people from
those communities now this community
suffer because there's less people to
take care of the kids or the
generational pieces or no role models
which then exacerbates into people not
being able to get jobs provide her
family or aren't able to get higher
level jobs because they're just trying
to take as much as they can to feed the
family and you know there's a recent
study that came out that said people of
color particularly African America
that are born into wealth oftentimes the
next generation are less wealthy then
you know you know white Caucasian and so
you're already have a predisposition in
color against you as well so I think if
we were to change it we really need to
change the social fabric and like the
regulatory fabric of how we we regulate
and you know imprison people you know in
California with prop 64 you know we've
been able to remove people's records
from from that right from having
anything related to marijuana fence like
those are steps in the right direction
it's about rebalancing and providing
economic opportunity to people that are
are that don't have it but you know when
you look at our healthcare system when
you look at you know our housing issue
it may mean housing here is is insane
right people need to be able to get up
the rung and instead of like a slide
that just keeps pushing you back down it
should really be a ladder and those
rungs really start from a basis of
security right having a place where you
can put your head at night and be okay
it comes from you know getting a salary
which allows you to provide for your
family
and it allows upward mobility and what's
crazy about cannabis we're at the
beginning of this thing if it's done
right there's cities are implementing
equity programs or cities that are
bringing in people that you know want
this want this opportunity ahead that's
gonna take a lot man it's going to
education right people need to get
retooled I like the ladder the ladder
the LED D yard
yeah I'm not later'd ladder yes the
ladders are the right metaphor for
people that are in the 4 billion right
now so at the top there what are the
ladders for the 4 billion that exists in
today's world who's making those ladders
right maybe Bill and Melinda Gates
eradicating polio I'm helping with
malaria other organizations across the
world
that are providing food and water
cleaning food water to people to meet
those basic needs yeah but shouldn't
that be if we truly believe that this
was a roll of the dice
Hoover medium have been born in the
United States then I could have just as
easily been born somewhere where the
average daily use in u.s. dollars is
less than 25 cents yeah so it doesn't
have become a global issue a global
issue and also a then if you got lucky
on your dice roll don't you feel like I
would want to help the people that need
more ladders then they need those
ladders to go up with that upward
mobility or despite I totally agree with
you but you know I'm it's hard for some
I think someone to say okay I live in
San Francisco there's already all these
problems that you're seeing right in
front of us right yes and it's like
there's such a local engagement issue
and there's a local piece to this that
if everyone engages locally then you can
affect globally and you know oftentimes
there isn't that engagement because
people are in that rat race they're just
trying to keep going they don't have
time to go to City Hall they don't have
time to read over all these bills they
don't have time and so then it comes to
you know these elected officials to
create a framework that benefits people
but oftentimes like you have lobbyists
and you have other interests and special
interests and corporations that have
more influence and necessarily the
people and it's like yeah it's
unfortunate but it's a it's one of those
things where I hope as people get more
information of accesses us to to you
know to come up and demand that these
ladders are available for people demand
that tuition isn't super high demand
that like you know there's an ability
for someone to get retrained and retold
into a new industry that you know
important it's gonna be scary I think
because when you look at AI and machine
learning over the last I guess hundred
years the GDP kind has doubled every 20
years I think
four thousand every 40 right so if we
apply the same thing maybe it's gonna
double every ten maybe every five yeah
and then if that happens and all of a
sudden we're talking about career
changes the entire industry changes
every ten five years like yeah Wow yeah
like it cemented reality is gonna be a
really important thing for for
retraining people right um yeah we were
just talking about that with shale
Israel on our previous show with our
previous guests okay that was good
what's a couple quickies to wrap up
cookies quick how about are we alone in
the cosmos are we alone in the cosmos
wow what a question I hope not I really
hope not I think if we're the only
species in this whole experiment of the
universe we have a huge responsibility
to like later [ __ ] together
Olivia Yeah right okay how about are we
in a computer simulation are we in a
computer simulation I did see the same
boosted board guy in the last three days
on my ride to work and I was like is
there a glitch in the matrix I have said
that um I also think that deja vu might
be a glitch team job who might be in the
matrix schizophrenia is a glitch it's a
friend yes I know some people may take
offense to that if they don't they don't
quite understand my taking it so lightly
and refer to referring to it as a
computer glitch but I in the bit are we
alone in the cosmos you know is this a
simulation you know who are we these
machines if it's a simulation though is
there an after simulation like if you
end what happens then are you saying
that you'd be rebooted as something else
which energy your conscious your
consciousness dies and that
is transferred you come in with that
energy if you have to simple you know
chisel it away well who what really
happens when you're dead then you know
it's just energy its energy and it's
whatever and so that's what you come in
with you know just that understanding
however it is yeah and if you go out
with being a nice [ __ ] then I don't know
you was that yeah I don't know oh yeah
what you what you take with you in yeah
I don't know I think collectively and
that's that boom the Karma we're all
suffering each other's Karma but the
Karma's visible in the day to day life
you smile other person smiles you
sterling the other person from yes
that's that's very very simple and
visible in day to day life okay
so quickly that was it how is it quickie
Ron Ron Ron Ron that that schizophrenia
being a glitch interesting well chat
will chat will chat more soon about that
these the machines have glitches it's
totally okay I'm gonna get in trouble
guards trouble they're good alright
let's ask okay who uh what's the most
beautiful thing in the world what's the
most beautiful thing in the world
love love is the most beautiful thing
right like because you can see it you
can feel it you can you can create it
and what's amazing is like mores more
right it's just two of us hanging out we
love each other amazing we grab a
thousand more favorite people even
better
well thousand people all let me imagine
like you love yeah imagine everyone just
like radiating love I think um loves the
most beautiful thing if we all seven and
half billion of us can love oh he's such
a better world
maybe such a better world and get there
in the near future we need to
desperately get there with all I really
wish we could make like push bombs and
just like push Bob just when I just like
in middle of like warp like everyone
just like oh and just like you know Jill
everyone out and just like okay my
friends Romo he goes he told me at the
ten day meditation retreat that we were
at in November he goes what's your
mission and I was like you know I want
to enlighten people around the world
help with that process yeah turn on the
light bulb yeah yeah yeah and he goes
here's what are you doing with this
vodcast just go micro dose the whole
foods buffet short guy really or they
might just love the buffet all right on
that note this was awesome yes this is a
lot of fun think we covered a lot of
ground though this was such a blast
thank you and thank you for coming out
of the program course thank you thank
you we'll put the links oh yeah
[Music]
thanks for tuning in everyone we
appreciate you so much we have a bunch
of links for get meadow Oh calm we'll be
we'll all be in the bio definitely give
them a toe a go check them out also if
you guys had a good time like comment
subscribe you already know let us know
what you think share the content with
other people if you found it to be
useful
let's get those cities slanging out
permits yeah seriously all day get that
can of tech rolling into the world help
people out with their medical cases that
they need it for and then become a
patron we survived here in our studio
with our equipment providing good time
for people because of you guys at home
so join us on patreon.com force less
simulation series and get exclusive
benefits for doing that thank you so
much we'll see you tomorrow everyone
peace
[Music]